spoilers there are be careful you must
I'm Kate and this is your gamespot news
update everyone's favorite little green
Jedi almost made it into the force
awakens Yoda was considered to be in the
film alongside other classic Star Wars
actors but he was cut before the film
hit theaters the Star Wars films editors
Marianne Brandon and Mary Jo markie
spoke to Entertainment Tonight at the
66th annual acee eddie awards about the
legendary yet mysterious Jedi Master
there was one point where we were
actually thinking of having Yoda in the
film and then we decided not to brandon
told ET Frank Oz came in for a day and
did a whole bunch of Yoda and he was
over the moon to do it and we were
tickled pink Yoda would have appeared in
the force vision scene with obi-wan
actors Alec Guinness and Ewan McGregor
in other star wars news it was confirmed
that the chromed out captain phasma will
return in episode 8 and if you're still
following the force awakens
record-breaking rise in the box office
its nearing the two billion dollars mark
do you mind missing out on Yoda let me
know in the comments or come and find me
on Twitter I'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it gamespot
you